texas attorney general ken paxton is
here to react mr attorney general great
to see you this morning i imagine as you
hear mayor adams
you have to agree in some part this is a
drain on services
imagine you disagree on it being a
despicable act by texas to send this
burden to new york
well good morning yeah that we've been
dealing with with this exact issue for
well over a year and a half we've dealt
with over a million immigrants coming
into our state i do believe that the
federal government should do something
not only should they help us they should
enforce the law and stop it from
happening so we've asked for help the
entire year and a half we've gotten none
they are now cooperative they continue
to cooperate with the with the
cartels and they're leaving all of us in
a horrible situation including now new
york city you know
i i wouldn't
mayor adams isn't entirely wrong to say
this is a political act by governor
abbott to send these illegal immigrants
to new york city into washington d.c
it's a statement
governor abbott yourself texas is
sending a statement
what is the statement you're sending to
new york city and to the federal
government
well part of it is that we have a
significant problem on board they're
only experiencing a slight bit of this i
mean it's it's almost a little
inconvenience for them it's a major
problem for us and so it's just
interesting to see some of these mayors
who have invited and have created
sanctuary cities to suddenly start
complaining that they've gotten a few
thousand immigrants when we're dealing
with millions so it's kind of a
statement of first of all fairness and
hey why don't you pay attention to our
real problem on the border you're
experiencing just a small part of it
and i think that point is very well
illustrated and then also there's this
there's the inconsistency of
establishing yourself as a sanctuary
city and then decrying those who take
advantage of the sanctuary
yeah i mean it's it's somewhat
hypocritical you act like you really
think this is a great idea until it
actually affects you and then when you
have a star you have to start dealing
with the crime and the drugs and the
cost of it in just a small way suddenly
it becomes a real problem it's not such
a great idea but everybody's great if
it's just texas or arizona if it's a
border state it's fine that we're
dealing with a massive problem and then
when they're dealing with a small
problem becomes a real real issue
uh mr attorney general just a um a
question on on logistics how does this
work i've seen the governor say that all
of the migrants to go to new york city
are doing so voluntarily just how does
that work you asked and now we've seen
the video by the way i think there's
venezuelans uh central americans uh hey
who wants to go to new york and and 50
people raise their hand how does this
work
it's just that simple there's no there's
no the governor's not forcing them to go
to new york or forcing them to go to
washington dc that's what's kind of
ironic about the the mayor's complaining
about these are people that volunteer
that actually want to go to these places
and yet these mayors have a problem with
these volunteers coming to their state
and they start blaming governor abbott
for the problem why don't they deal with
the real problem which is a federal
government administration that will not
enforce federal law not only that they
they tell the cartels hey bring as many
people here as you can you'll make a lot
of money and we'll take care of them
what happens next the governor governor
abbott says this is just the beginning
i think that's right i think all of
these cities and there may be more are
going to start dealing with just a touch
of the problem that we have and
hopefully
all of these cities will start realizing
that it's not just border states that
are suffering now they're suffering
right even just to small degree they're
having to deal with some of the major
problems that we're dealing with just
really quickly um 50 that's the number
that arrived yesterday if this is just
the beginning can you give mayor adams
any sense of expectation what kind of
numbers could be headed to new york city
look it's it's a volunteer basis so we
never know for sure but i can tell you
this it's gonna it's gonna keep as long
as the biden administration encourages
the cartels to bring as many people here
as possible those numbers are going to
continue to go go up and they're going
to be dealing with at least some of the
problem that we're dealing with i would
expect it to to go on as long as the
fight administration is violating
federal law attorney general ken paxton
of texas thank you so much for joining
us
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis